vorher hatte war dabei ist luca meine
damen und herren ich habe bereits vor
einigen jahren ein video auf diesem
kanal hochgeladen namens der tödlichste
chemiker ja ich bin wirklich nicht der
allerschnellste in chemie auf jeden fall
hat dieses video mittlerweile fast drei
millionen aufrufe und viele von euch
haben dort in die kommentare geschrieben
ich soll auch einen zweiten teil
hochladen von daher habe ich mir einen
weiteren chemie labor basis
ausstattungskosten gekauft ich bin
mindestens genauso heute wie dieses
mädchen in diesem spiel an bord kassen
für kinder haben wie chemikalien wir
haben trägt am westbad bierglas bürste
peppen pro biergläser wickel oder
schutzbrille
ich bin wie albert einstein in diesem
wechsel relativ hatten sind auf jeden
fall viele verschiedene stoffe und
gegenstände drin das heißt wir werden
heute station nobelpreis kriegen
allerdings müssen wir zunächst natürlich
sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen das
heißt dieses wunderschöne t shirt das am
den lukas abkommen wird superminister
von de dieses t shirt wird nur überdeckt
von einem titel den ich hier vorbereitet
habe das ist mein chemie kittel aus dem
irakkrieg 1830 habe ich im unterricht
wird bevor wir nun anfangen hier mit
lebensbedrohlichen chemikalien
herumzuexperimentieren lesen uns
natürlich das komplette buch hier mit
der jetzt sich seiten erklärung wer
braucht denn die scheiße ich hätte
erfahren als chemiker weiss natürlich
worum es hier geht und was auch jeder
einzelne substanz bedeutet ich hab mir
schon einige sachen vorbereitet die
unter anderem messer ich habe schon der
perfektion sprayt organisierte das
funktioniert fast damit wie scheiße
alter und hat man habe ich auch ein
feuerzeug das funktioniert sogar
allerdings würde ich sagen wir fangen
jetzt direkt mal an und nehmen uns hier
aus diesem niveau kasten einen sonnen
griechen raus
das sind 125 milliliter und ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt mit der ersten
chemikalie die wir haben das ist nämlich
lackmus pulver muss los pulver wie die
rede den ganzen ab
hat jetzt einfach mal bin ich bescheuert
die anleitung er weiß doch was wir
brauchen hier so ein deckel heben müssen
wir hier reinstecken und dann ach du
scheiße wieder blut opel quasi die
künftige mischung aus es ist einfach ich
habe schon alles an den händen hätte
allererstes nehmen wir eine prise von
dem lack muss das war alles das ist
unsere bisherige mischung lackmus pulver
ist in den gefäßen drin die kugeln erst
mal ganz kurz was laclos pulver
überhaupt ist las muss ist eines
bestimmten flechtenarten gewonnener blau
violetter farbstoff die wässrige lösung
besitzt die eigenschaft ihre farbe zu
ändern was hier sollte eine farbe
verändert heißt die spritzen bisschen
desinfektion skillman dann schauen wir
mal ob er seine farbe es ist es einfach
nur schwarzes wasser rann blumenkohl mit
desinfektionsspray allerdings haben wir
noch einige weitere stoffe und zwar zäh
67 lkw zitronensäure also sprite quasi
gab in dem wir natürlich auch wieder
unseren tollen hebel mich allerdings
booms und ich will man ja also es ist
auf jeden fall null komma null nach
breit deswegen will ich sagen gibt
manchmal alles hier ein alter alter ich
weiß nicht ob ihr das seht aber es
passiert etwas drin sieht man dass es
blubbert sogar
die mutter war ihr alter vor altera
fried ja schlimmer als ein kurz nach den
feiern
das habe ich ihn hier kreiert es hat
sich von komplett schwarz jetzt zu so
rothenkirchen wie entwickelt wir haben
ja noch weitere stoffe wie unter anderem
zu so 45 h 2 o t kupfer sulfat
mitmenschen dass ein toter fisch diese
symbole bedeuten halt nie was gutes
alter ich glaube wenn ich länger selbst
weg nach diesem video also so sieht
dieses kupfer sulfat von innen aus das
sieht aus wie sonnen blauer lapislazuli
von minecraft allerdings lagern bei gar
nicht sagen warum ich finde nicht
langweilig im meedia sondern der haut
alles rein kommt die doppel nach 20
minuten sport monster kreiert freunde
das richtige rad echt nach seiner
mischung aus also dinosaurier scheiße so
richtig zehn quadratmeter städte laden
dann blumenkohl desinfektionsspray und
ja ich weiß ja dass das trifft es ganz
gut allerdings mal weiter mit unserer
komische mischung hier als nächstes
produkt haben wir hier darf nicht an die
haut verursacht hautreizungen und
schwere augenreizungen h4 fwg ammonium
eisensulfat ich wünschte echtes könnten
irgendwann mal gerüchte über seinen
kameras ich habe so sind diese kaka aus
von der ich gerade den namen vergessen
habe es darf auf jeden fall nicht an die
haut geraten das heißt die bagger noch
erstmal alles wieder da kommt nichts
raus
also so sieht unsere mischung die
mittlerweile aus er mich also ich will
nicht wissen junge wieviel solchen davon
noch einen hut kriegen alle unter euch
die sich mit chemie auskennen er
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
ob ammonium eisensulfat wirklich so
schlimm ist hier steht das ist doch ein
bisschen mehr an meiner hand ist aber
nicht weiter schlimm noch lebe ich ja
eher das darin sieht aus wie der pure
tod befestigt wie kalium das wir haben
ist er also kalzium hydrox itm ist ach
du scheiße ich würde sagen dass wir dass
ich jetzt mal in einem neuen behälter
packen in ein gläschen aus mamas lgh
schublade deswegen ab handicap sieht da
bleibt doch über von sage mir den rest
einfach mal hier in unsere komische
mischung hier rein und unseren schweiz
hier schlugen kohl desinfektionsspray
bringt alter sieht man dass die panik
vor allem ich weiß habe das auf der
kamera rüberkommt aber es qualmt
mittlerweile das habe ich noch an meiner
brille
wir haben noch zwei stoffe hier meine
damen und herren einmal kalium hexion
overath erst mal zeit und natrium caron
atrium karbonat ist glaube ich gar nicht
weiter schlimm und es mich wieder in
dieser haut reizt kacke gefasst und
jetzt ist auch noch an meinem ohr auf
jeden fall von natrium kamen auch wieder
eine menge das heißt ein bisschen kommt
wieder in unseren tollen dringt hier
rein und der rest kommt in unserem
becher aktiven festen stoffen da doch
bestimmt auch hätte dass das quad und es
blubbert und jetzt hat es alle diese
kaka aufgefressen
ich war bei der aufnahme mit myphone
davon leben gibt euch dass leute was
kreiere ich hier gerade für ein monster
diese blase ist mittlerweile so fett
geworden ich steckte sie schon selbst
geplatzt wir noch von komischen starb
der hat uns ein bisschen viel drauf und
darunter ist er so schon die besten
zeiten hinter sich
ich würde sagen wir haben erstmal volker
vereinfacht in dieses ding rein
das sieht aus wie verschimmelte schimmel
gesagt das brauchen wir nicht mehr
deswegen packt er das jetzt erstmal hier
noch eine seite wir haben hier noch
einig dass ich habe ich komplett dunkel
aber das sieht dass elektrizität aus
also brennen tut's nicht steht strebt
aber schon wenn wir noch weitere von
diesem komischen pipetten teilen einmal
anzünden passiert ist nur ein bisschen
von meiner zeitung abgebrannt ich glaube
das kommt nicht richtig rüber also das
kann man auf jeden fall schon mal ein
wenig anzünden
wir haben immer noch ein wenig kalium
hacks aktionäre übrig gelbes blutsaugen
salz worte [ __ ] das ist so eine gelbe
chemikalien die bands auch volle kanone
wieder hier drauf ja natürlich ist
privat wieder wie kacke und dann haben
wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
desinfektionsspray rain god alter also
mittlerweile ist das hier wirklich die
komplette ausgeburt der hölle hin oh
mein gott des blau am rand die
farbmischung ist mittlerweile roth volvo
farben blau und unten rum so ein
bisschen schwarz ich würde sagen wir
versuchen noch mal das hier anzuzünden
meine nase war noch nie so frei das ist
bei rausgekommen bei unserem heutigen
video das nice
ich hoffe der feuerwehr dagegen beide
fenster in meinem zimmer sind auf und
ich kann nicht atmen also es geht nicht
an der jenny wird das häufig wird jetzt
auch beenden meine damen und herren wenn
euch luc picard teil 2 der erste teil
den habe ich ja vor zwei jahren oder so
schon mal hochgeladen habe ich euch auch
unten wir beschreiben oder mal verlinkt
wenn euch allerdings dieses heutige
video hier gefallen hat und ich
eventuell nochmal einen kasten stellen
soll weil es gibt 20.000 verschiedene
chemie gestern hinterlasse einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video hier da schreiben
mir bitte gerne in die kommentare mit
welchen krankheiten nicht zu rechnen
habe wir tun eigentlich alles in diesem
bereich gerade w
[Musik]